s
Labeaume. Louis-Philippe Ouimet
a rencontré Serge Fiori.
- Yé! Bravo!
- Serge Fiori rêvait depuis
plusieurs années de faire de
longues entrevues avec certains
de ses amis. Le rêve est devenu
réalité avec le projet
"Chez  Serge Fiori".
SERGE FIORI, auteur-compositeur
interprète
- Ça s'en va dans 11 places
avec 11 grandes personnes,d'apr,
leur intérêt.
C'est fantastique!
Moi je sortais... je sortait
de ces entrevues-là comme...
bouleversé.
Tu étai à la bonne
place.
- Mais tu sais, ça été... tu
sais, j'ai surtout travaillé
au théâtre...- Pour ces émissios
sur le Web, le cofondateur du
groupe Harmonium a recueilli,
dans sa maison du Lac St-Jean,
les confidences entre autres
d'Anne Dorval, de Luc Picard
et de France Castel.
L'entrevue avec Michel Côté
a été filmée un an avant son
retrait de la vie publique, pour
recevoir des traitements contre
une maladie de la moëlle
osseuse.
- Je veux pas révéler toutes les
affaires dans cett dans cett daà
mais c'était comme...
... il a quasiment dit un peu
où sa vie s'en allait, sans
le savoir.
- Mon père, c'est un gars de
Roberval qui a été adopté.
- Serge Fiori a réalisé des
entretiens sans filtre et il a
amené Régis Labeaume à se
confier comme jamais auparavant.
RÉGIS LABEAUME,
ancien maire de Québec
- Je lui ai raconté mes échecs,
hein, je lui ai beaucoup parlé
de ma vie personnelle.
Je suis allé très loin parce
que c'était pour Serge. Et je me
suis surpris à être comme dans
mon salon, en train de prendre
une bière avec mon meilleur ami.
♪ Où est allé tout ce monde ♪
- Lors de ces rencontres,
Serge Fiori le musicien n'est
jamais loin de Serge Fiori
l'intervieweur, qui parfois
improvise.
- Peut-être parce que je fais
de la musique puis que ça,
ça t'apprend une écoute.
Ça vient peut-être de là.
Puis il y a une réponse
à l'écoute. Parce que t'as beau
avoir un musicien qui va
t'envoyer de quoi, tu l'écoutes
mais il faut que tu lui
renvoies.
- Serge Fiori sera très occupé
en 2022. En plus de ses
entrevues, il y a aussi
les concerts d'"Harmonium
symphonique" et il doit composer
une grande oeuvre orchestrale
pour souligner le 100e
anniversaire de naissance de
Jean-Paul Riopelle.
- Merci.
- Bravo!
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,